[Music]
this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host flying solo today we're
glad you're with us open phones at
triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight
eight two five five two two five john is
in atlanta georgia
hey john welcome to the ramsey show
how you doing today dave better than i
deserve sir what's up in your world
uh dave uh where it is uh i work for my
father
and uh we're in the construction
business um
pretty large company we've got 40
employees um
about seven million top line uh
gross but anyways i'm 29 years old i've
been working with them for 10 years now
and uh i'm working around 60 to 65 hours
a week
and i'm wondering
uh i've talked to him about scaling back
my hours but he
you know continues to emphasize you know
you need to put your time in you need to
work and
financially i have all my ducks in a row
like you teach
um you know i've got emergency funds
well and uh well more than what you
teach
and uh out of debt and i'm just kind of
wondering am i wrong for want to
uh drop my hours back because i have a
wife and two kids
and um just kind of want to know your
thoughts
on that yeah the only time i work that
amount of hours or ask somebody to work
that amount of hours is for a
sprint a short season to knock something
out now the short season could be
for a year uh it could even be for two
years but it's
you know while we're trying to get
something up and moving or there's an
emergency
uh and it falls under the heading of uh
you know country sayings but
you know make hay while the sun shines
right and so if you got to put in
16-hour days get the hay out of the
field before the rain kills it
uh and kills your dadgum crop you got to
go do that shut up
you know and if you uh and the other one
is get the ox out of the ditch meaning
there's
something's broken right it's something
and we got to get the
you know we got to get that item fixed
so if the servers go down around here my
guys here are here two in the morning
but they're not here at two in the
morning every week it's because
something broke
right yeah and i'm not here because i
can't even spell servers so it wouldn't
do any good for me to be here unless i
hand in somebody some coffee but
but you know so the question is is this
a way of life
or is this the fact that we're in the
middle of a construction boom and you
guys need to get the hay out of the
field
well it's a way of life i mean we've
been doing it like i said
it's uh you know and he's worked he's
worked 60 70 hours his whole life
and that's just what he does well i like
hard-working people okay as opposed to
lazy people
they're handy to have around but when
i'm coaching small business people if i
was coaching you're all small business
based on what you just told me i would
say you have a breakdown
in staffing whatever it is you are
doing with that 60 hours you need to
hire somebody to do part of it
if all of that time is spent in
leadership that means you guys don't
have enough leadership in the
organization
you need to put some supers in there and
have some money come out of your pocket
so you get a quality of life back
if you're in there swinging a hammer
then you need to get somebody else in
there swinging a hammer part of the time
or whatever it is
that you could get your life back
because you know when i started this
thing
i mean sharon ramsey will tell you she
was a single mom for two years
freaking 16 hour days man i mean i was
busting it but that was for 18 to 24
months to get the airplane off the
ground
but once it's in the air you can
throttle back it doesn't take as much
fuel to keep it flying as it does to get
it off the ground
and so that's that that's the
distinction i make
and but if your dad is signing you up
for 30 more years of workaholism
i'll pass yeah
well i sure i sure appreciate dave just
been stuck on the fence and just trying
to
kind of just get some you know i trust
your opinion well
here's the thing he's not as good
at his job when he's working 60 hours a
week year in and year out
because you're freaking tired your brain
doesn't work as good
and so you're not as good a leader
you're not as good an estimator
you're not as good at whatever it is
you're doing during that time
because you're tired i mean you can do
it for a sprint
but you can't do this over an extended
period of time and get the maximum use
out of the business it's a bad business
decision
but i mean i i understand i grew up in a
household where the answer to
everything's work
you know shut up and go to work you know
so i get it i get the i
and i'm kind of that way wired inside
but i've had to learn
to be a little bit more sophisticated
business owner and say
if i have a team that's working 60 hours
that means i've understaffed the area
yeah and and and i'll get better
efficiency and better quality results
out
if i'll properly staff it's kind of like
you know
never taking off on sunday take off on
sunday god said rest today you know why
because your productivity goes up
dramatically in the other six days
if you rest a day if you bust all the
way through seven days you don't get the
productivity studies tell us you don't
get it the results
and it's the same thing here so i would
make the case to your dad if i were you
now we need to rethink this this is what
got us here
and i honor you for your hard work all
these years you built this with the
sweat of your brow and the calluses on
your hand and i love you
and i honor you and i respect you but
we're our business has grown to a point
we need to reach a better level of
sophistication
where we can have a life and oh by the
way we can't attract good quality people
if we work them like donkeys if we send
them into the salt mines and don't let
them out
you know nobody wants to work for us
because of this
and so that that's you know i think you
can make the case to him but if he
absolutely just says no i own it shut up
you're gonna do what i say
then dude i guess you're gonna have to
hit the eject button but that'll be real
painful for him and you
because his dream is for you to work
with him and it's a joy to work with
your
son when you can or your daughter when
you can i have the joy of doing
both and uh but uh you know
there's no question you have to you have
to look at this through
some some good strong eyes good question
man we appreciate you joining us
not something i usually have to coach
someone on less work
you just have to coach them on more work
you know
it's oh man
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five the bible says i've been
young
and i've been old but i've never seen
the righteous
or their seed bread
also says the diligent prosper diligence
is excellence in the ordinary over time
diligent people prosper i've been young
and i've been old but i've never seen
the righteous or their seed their ch
their kids begging bread you just don't
want to read proverbs unless you
understand work ethic
because the bible's really clear that
work is where money comes from and it's
also where dignity comes from
the fact that you throw your shoulders
back and move some stuff around out in
the marketplace
builds your self-confidence it builds
your personal
value the tipping point is when
you're doing it 80 hours a week since
why we don't have any trouble hiring
developers we
can never get enough of them because
we're growing so fast but we get
these ruby on rails guys and these
platform architecture guys because we
work
40 hours a week in the tech world they
all work 80 hours a week
they work those guys into the dead gum
dirt and they come to work here and they
get to do work
that matters and they're here 40 hours a
week so we're a highly attractive
position for people in the tech world by
the way just check
we're hiring at davram
ramseysolutions.com check it out
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm dave ramsey
your host one of the beautiful things
about
living in nashville and doing business
here is i've gotten to meet
really cool really famous people and
become friends with a few of them
and uh want them just stopped by a
minute ago so michael w
smith uh is in the studio 45
dove awards uh more than 15 million
albums uh mr christian music for sure
the worship music and stuff is
absolutely unbelievable and he's got a
new book out
uh that caleb did with him uh the way of
the father just in time
for father's day how you doing brother
i'm doing good good good pull that up
just a little bit there you go
good to see you you too man and it's
been a while
has been i think we bumped into each
other on golf course the other day we
did you you were coming out and i was
going in
yeah something like that but that was in
millikova there was nobody out there
i know and we were the but you were lone
ones out there swinging
uh hanging out so this is a great
lessons from my dad truths about god
now a lot of people don't know this but
i've heard a lot of your testimony a lot
of your story over the years because we
work together on a lot of
different things that you grew up in
west virginia
so tell us about paul smith dad
in west virginia yeah that's there's got
to be some stuff there there's a there's
a lot of stuff
he came from that great generation that
when you were sick you went to work
yeah you know blue collar oil refinery
swing shift days then the evenings then
you know all night you know and uh he
hardly ever missed
coaching me in baseball and uh dave he
was like
he was the kindest man i'd ever known
who happened to be my dad
and um i knew one day i would write a
book about him
uh when he got dementia in 2011 that's
when i
started to recollect all these amazing
stories about my dad and um
he passed went to heaven in november 15.
and
2020 was a good time to write a book
yeah so it was a good time
on our hands yeah yeah yeah wow
so little known fact you actually are uh
good at baseball as well as music
well i was as a kid i wanted to i wanted
to play for the cincinnati reds
i was the big red machine yes my dad
used to take me to crosley field
oh really yeah so that's that really
shows you how old i am so
coming out coming out of west virginia
so yeah
he had a dream of you playing baseball i
think he did he he really had a dream to
play baseball
um matter of fact he was a great ball
player and i was a i think i was a
pretty good ballplayer because of him
um he went to the minor leagues uh
but he made a decision one day that he
had to come and take care of his mom
his father died of a heart attack when
he was 16.
and but his dream was to play major
league ball but he came back and took
care of his mom
and uh so that's the kind of man my dad
was so he kind of lived out that dream
through me a little bit but he never
ever pressured me to stay in baseball so
when you went music versus baseball won
the problem oh
he became my pr agent just telling
everybody how great it was all the time
i said
dad you got to stop that you don't have
to do that all the time he said why not
son you're
you're the best he'd say he affirmed me
my whole life yeah yeah
so i remember you telling the story we
had a an event that you and amy and
stephen curtis did with us together
which was like having the mount rushmore
of christian music right there in one
i remember that night yeah it was pretty
pretty iconic
and i remember you telling the story on
uh i believe it was friends
i believe uh whatever whatever your
fourth that was that the first big hit
that you wrote like a bazillion songs
before anybody
before one of them caught right i read a
lot of songs they were pretty bad
you know i was on the learning curve in
the early days
but i mean didn't you have a like you
had a a seriously large catalog
before anything yeah i had 150 songs
yeah yeah i mean you were it wasn't like
you just sat down and
uh lightning struck on the first song
and you're in you're a
multi-platinum no that's not how it
works it kind of
slow what made me think about that was
is his work ethic was transferred to you
it was because you you applied that to
your songwriting
yep and you know that okay because a lot
of people don't realize songwriting is
is work like a lot of other things yeah
and it's hard to write a good song
being in the studio and getting
something arranged and getting it right
i know nothing about music but i know a
lot of folks in the music business and
they
work right and you're on the road it's
work
right it's it's fun and you get the you
you do a whole lot of stuff to get to
spend three and a half minutes on the
stage
right yeah you know i i
a lot of my work ethic comes from my dad
yeah and uh
he was a hard worker um you know
the way he loved my mom loved my sister
and i the his community he worked in the
homeless shelter
he's always giving himself away the
thing that used to drive my drive me a
little crazy
i built two houses with my dad and if it
was off
he was a perfectionist if it was off
just by like
one thirty seconds of an end he would
take it apart i said dad it's okay
nobody's gonna notice
not right it's not right so he was
that was the only thing that drove me
crazy about my dad but
his work ethic was pretty incredible the
book is the way of the father by michael
w smith lessons
from my dad truths about god
so how did he transfer truths about god
to you he showed me what god was like
i think on so many levels he um
he's always was for me my whole life
it was never based on performance you
know i got that whole story at the
beginning of the book where
i was on this little league team and
he's coaching us and and
we had 16 games and we were 0 and 15 we
were awful
and if you won you got to go to dairy
queen
then we got beat 30 to nothing that
first game 30 to nothing
i remember it i was eight years old
thrashing and uh
and my dad walked in that dugout you
know we got our heads hung like the
it was into the world my dad walked in
says boys
we'll get him next time let's go to
dairy queen oh
and every time we went to dairy queen 15
times in a row and then that last game
we won we won i remember at the exact
remember every detail i was on second
base somebody hit a run i
was scoring run three to two we won the
game
and we were just thought we won the
world series my dad walks in the dugout
and says boys
great job let's go to dairy queen
we go to dairy queen the times we lost
those the you know the winning team
would be in there going what are you
guys doing here we just annihilated you
but he took his dairy queen 16 times
and i tell that story because he never
based his love
um for me and my teammates it was never
based on performance he just
he just uh affirmed us all growing up
so the michael w smith your soundtrack
your your music is the soundtrack for so
many of our
faith walks so many of our lives your
family five adult kids
sixteen grandkids they call me g daddy's
seven man papa dave's got seven but i
think that's sixteen
wow you can catch up be fruitful man i'm
telling you
do these are your family members
and did your dad did they grasp how
big this your music career had become
how many because it went so exponential
you've touched people you'll never see
never hear
i mean there's just bazillions of
connection points out there right
did they get do they get it and did he
get it
yes yes and yes um
but but you would you know i live a very
normal life but i live an extraordinary
life too
but at home i've just i'm just dad
just dad i'm just you know i don't have
bodyguards and i don't
live some crazy lifestyle of
of the rich and famous i just i'm just
dead and um
i go to the store like everybody else
does you know so
if you would talk to my kids i think
they would all tell you
i think this is true that they were more
important to me than my career
we always did the two-week rule never
away never away from home more than two
weeks ever and
we've we've held on to that rule
sure that's why i've been married almost
40 years september yeah me too
me too and both because both of us
married up yes we did what that was
we did so talk about him i love this
scene in the book where he's dancing in
the aisle while you're singing
yeah we look out there and all these you
know back in the day these all these
kids are just going crazy and there's
this old guy out there go who's that guy
and go oh my gosh that's my dad
he's out there singing every word to
every song
and dancing with these teenagers i love
it fatherhood is something that's uh
going to be one of the things as it
comes back as there was a revival in
fatherhood that
heals this culture we need our dads yes
we do we need our dads
the way of the father michael w smith
lessons from my dad
truths about god pick it up i highly
recommend anything my friend here does
and this book is no exception be sure
you check it out this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage
joshua and ashley are with us hey guys
how are you
hi hi dave welcome welcome where do you
guys live uh
middleport new york which isn't quite
buffalo it's
not quite rochester it's just out there
in the middle so
go bells middle port middleport new york
all right cool i got it
so welcome to nashville that's a bit of
a hall i can tell you that yes
long drive so how much did you uh how
much did you guys pay off
87 0026 months good for you and your
range of income during that time
100 to 110. all right what do y'all do
for a living
i am a food scientist for a chocolate
manufacturer
yum yes so am i
after that how do you follow that right
yeah
oh my gosh way to go you guys so how
what kind of debt was this 87
000 it was our house
look at the weird people yes yes we've
waited a long time to hear you say that
how old are you two uh i'm 33 i'm 32
and you have a paid for house you sure
do in middle port new york what's it
worth
uh one time probably 20. yeah 110 120
and it's yours
it is shut up
wow excellent job guys so what in the
world happened what inspired you guys to
be so weird yeah
it was a long journey back several years
ago
when we were living just outside of st
louis um
you know working hard every day and just
didn't have the money to do what we
needed to do and and really didn't
understand what was going on and
we said we need to make a plan because
we knew eventually we wanted to move
back to live with our family
and we weren't going to be able to do
that if we didn't get our finances in
order
so we just kind of we heard about your
book
read a few pages tried to get and really
weren't on the same page
so we kind of hemmed and had for a few
years on that and didn't make much
progress
and then we got the opportunity to move
back home and
from that point on we said okay we
really got to make a change here
so just after our youngest daughter was
born i had an opportunity to go back to
work
and uh it wasn't something that i was
expecting but we said
you know this is what we need to get
that house paid off and
and to do what we what we want to do and
uh if
if i work and sacrifice that time with
my children then uh we're gonna make our
money work
yeah we're gonna get tracked we're gonna
do what we need to do yeah so yeah i
think it was a lot of chaos uh
uh we always had good intentions but no
plan yeah it was never a uh
so what about that decision made you
guys get on the same page when you
didn't before
uh i think it was you know it was um
we went to a wedding on new year's eve
and um you know we were talking about
what are our goals for this year what
are we gonna do
and you know josh said well this might
sound a little crazy but we really need
to pay the house off
when we moved back we had paid off all
the rest of our debt and uh
you know it was just that mortgage and
we just we still felt that burden of it
and he said you know we really
we really need to make this happen and
so on the drive home from that wedding
on new year's day we we got out the
every dollar app and we
we built our first budget together you
know we both had kind of tried to do
things here and there on our own before
and we said nope this is it and it
probably took us the whole car ride an
hour
and and we said okay we got this now and
you know we we fumbled for the first few
months but
that was it once we had that plan and we
knew where we had to go
we said we got this too that she had
gotten your book before and read it
while we were still
by the illinois side um i'm not much of
a book reader to go with so i was like
okay whatever it was until we moved home
i heard
you on the radio and i came home like
you gotta listen to this guy yeah he's a
genius she's like i read his book that's
the one in illinois i tried to give him
i was like oh yeah well there we go yeah
there's that the combination between the
rave show and the book is an audio
learner once
again everybody's got their own way of
getting at it
that's awesome then we found the
everydollar app and that just that
that just turned everything around yeah
just every dollar got the rid of the
credit cards
and uh just did the debit card and one
bank account and
from there it was like boom game high it
was it was crazy
well it was a process yeah what took us
you know
nine years loans and a car loan um we
did
our house in two years you know and we
make less now than we did before so
go figure that right well it's amazing
what a plan does it's the difference in
being on the same page yeah
having a plan and sticking to the plan
yep yeah that's everything yes
you don't have a payment in the world
nope how does that feel
it's just light there's just nothing
holding us
back you know and it was it took us a
while to get here but
it's something that we did together and
now when i turn and look at him
i i just i feel unstoppable like we can
do anything together we've done this
and there's you know there's going to be
more things that are going to come our
way
and uh we're going to get it we're going
to get through it because
we know how to work together now i had
you plugged into my ear for about two
years working you know just every day
listening to these podcasts it was
awesome those debt free screens helped
me go crazy yeah
my work got the most out of me as they
could 200 percent of me probably
yeah definitely every every overtime
opportunity the big thing
the big why right i got three wise
sitting there there to the right of me
right now and
let me tell you that'll spark some uh
something for you yeah absolutely yeah
absolutely we'll bring them up what are
their names and ages all right so we've
got uh
noah hunter and evelyn and noah
sometimes is a little shy so he might
choose to sit back
so this is hunter is five and evelyn is
almost three and she's not shy she does
not
no she don't care she's ready for the
camera thank you for her too she's cute
well done well done you guys well we're
so proud of you guys
i mean you are absolutely stellar early
30s
with a paid for house not a payment in
the world
and you know making 110 000 you guys can
do anything you want to do like you said
you're unstoppable now
it's all good yeah who was your biggest
cheerleader
uh outside of you guys uh our families
were
very supportive i mean you know josh
took every opportunity
he could for overtime and our parents
stepped in helped with babysitting and
just said go you can do this you got
this actually
some co-workers i would converse about
you and actually probably got them on
your plan too so
yeah well that's healthy this you won
i mean yeah i paid off my house i mean
how do you debate this
right you know right it's kind of like
done then that's like done mic dropped
yeah but it was healthy discussion right
like oh yeah hey what are you doing what
am i doing like how much did you get
when you're carlo and awesome you know
keep going
yeah it's a nice friendly race i guess
yeah accountability encouragement
competition
all that yeah very good good stuff all
right we've got a copy of the legacy
journey for you because that's the next
chapter like you said these are your
whys your legacy and uh make sure you
change your whole family tree
never go back in debt got a copy of the
total money makeover for you to give to
somebody pay it forward and maybe you
can get them to read two pages
and then they'll be standing here a few
years later with a paid for house you
never know it's a magical book you read
two pages you get all this results
pretty cool good stuff i'm so proud of
y'all thank you well done you are you're
an
inspiration all this material for us
well you're an inspiration
joshua and ashley noah hunter and
evelyn from middleport new york 87
000 paid off house and
everything in 26 months making 100 to
110
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
right three two one we're dead
[Applause]
that is how it's done
that's how it's done wow
you know uh if your why
has some nobility to it if why you're
doing something is more noble than just
selfishness it drives you harder
it'll make you sacrifice deeper if the
only reason you want to be out of debt
is so you can get rich so
you can buy a filet mignon for yourself
that's not evil that's not bad it just
doesn't motivate you like
looking into your kid's eyes and going
their kids
are gonna be changed because of what i'm
doing right now
when you start talking about changing
your family tree uh
if you're a parent and you have like a
heart that beats in your chest
hit changes your level of commitment
it changes your level of sacrifice to
win
if your why has some nobility then your
why
has some power this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsey show we're glad
you're with us america thank you for
joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five jennifer's in minneapolis
hi jennifer how are you
hi dave it's an honor to speak with you
today you too how can i help
we have a question about baby step 3b
because we want to move
significantly up in house a question is
in this market we understand contingent
offers are generally not
accepted so we have been advised to
consider a bridge loan
what would you say i would say the idiot
that advised you that should agree to
pay the payments
okay um here's here's the problem
stuff like that doesn't work unless
everything goes perfect and everything
never goes perfect okay
okay let's just pretend that something
like a pandemic happened
okay i don't know i mean i never
never experienced anything like that but
let's say you were right in the middle
of this and you had one foot on the boat
and one on the dock and the boat was
leaving
you know where you're going to end up
and that's in the lake
meaning you're going to end up with a
bridge loan payment a house payment
and another house payment okay
can i get your numbers in our scenario
and you can tell me kind of what you
what i would do is sell your house and
go rent something while you buy if a
contingency won't work
okay and that's i that's what i
personally have done by the way
because see i'm more i'm worse off than
you because
i don't borrow money at all sure
and so i if i have to have the money out
of the house to buy the next house
i can't buy it
until i get the other one closed and so
that
that entails a double move or a
contingency offer
okay and so that's the only way around
because and and i've done that i've i
mean sharon and i have done that
not a whole bunch of times and it's not
ideal it's not my favorite
but uh and if you can get a really good
solid offer on your house it's a cash
offer
you know because the market's so hot
people are waving they're waving
appraisals they're waving everything and
they're just making offers right
waving inspections they're doing
everything and you get a good solid cash
offer on your house then you can make a
really good
solid contingency offer and talk them
into just waiting until yours closes
right quick because they ought to be
able to close them both within a week or
two and just run them back-to-back
dominoes it can be done
but it's uh it's very it is very hard it
is very hard
and it's harder it's more work for your
poor little realtor bless their little
heart
and so they're gonna get two commissions
the sale of yours and the purchase on
the other side and so they're just gonna
have to do their little work
uh instead of you getting a bridge loan
and getting caught in the middle please
don't do that
everything that can go wrong well you're
gonna meet mr murphy john is with us in
cincinnati hey john how are you
thanks thanks for taking my call um this
call is more about an opportunity
and with the real estate market so uh my
situation is
i'm a pastor here in cincinnati um i've
got about four or five more years till
my wife and i retire
right now our net worth is probably
about 1.5
um we thank you we own our house in
cincinnati
um its market value is about 500.
our only debt is our second home in
florida and we built the home
two years ago for 260
and our realtor the realtors down there
i mean obviously the market's
very very hot and the current market
value
of that host right now is about 450 000.
now they're getting cash offers you know
and it's only the 1400 square foot house
i think our long-term plan is when we do
retire we want to
move to florida get something a little
bit bigger to
for our family but i'm uh at the point
right now i'm just kind of like
trying to discern you know should i be
selling my house maybe take that money
pay off obviously the market could paid
off and put that money
more towards investments and you know
see what the market correction does
um it's just you know when it when the
house was worth 350 i was like tempted
and then it went up to 400 and now it's
up to 450. so
just looking for some guidance about
what would be the best thing for us to
do
especially looking at retirement in four
years is this property like beach
property
no actually it is in um it's in support
florida and and they have put in some
obviously some nice developments it's a
resort property
but it's uh single family houses uh
you know several resources centers the
most volatile
type of real estate is resort property
beach
mountain resort whatever in other words
it goes
up super fast and down super fast much
more so than traditional
housing does does that make sense like
i've got a lake house
and right now there's a there's just
absolutely no property for sale on that
lake and
people will just give you anything it's
just because it but
you know like in 2008 you couldn't give
away a house down there
i mean it was just the market just
disappears because resort property is
luxury money it's toys
and the first thing people quit buying
when times get hard is toys
and the thing they overspend on when
things are prosperous as toys
and so it just shoots way up and way
down is what it does so
i think you're riding the curve up it
sounds like you don't want to rest in
this house when you retire anyway it's
only 1400 and you want something bigger
yeah
i'm cashing out then okay on that yeah
the only flip side to the whole thing
was you know i also
stole the business uh and so this year
i'm looking at um you know looking at a
uh payout on the business for this year
about 250 000
and then obviously capital gains because
it's a second home in florida so
just trying to you know i know there's
no way we can hedge taxes but it just
seems like
you know well your capital gains rate
will be 15 on your gain okay
and it may not be after next year after
biden gets done
okay because they're talking about
jacking it up and you know yeah i know
you you rich people that have worked all
your life and built up a million and a
half in a little beach house you should
be punished and washington's going to
see to it
so um that's what the word is now
they've not actually proposed any
legislation but they've
they're making a lot of noise about how
much they're going to soak the rich so
and you qualify my friend thank god and
um
so anyway i don't know uh here's the
thing
given that that it's a 15 rate and it
might not be next year
given that this is volatile property and
it could be peaking it could go on up
from here
before it peaks but we don't know
given all of that if you had 450 000
sitting in the middle of your kitchen
table plus or minus some taxes
and you didn't own this house would you
go buy it and everything you told me
says the answer is no yeah absolutely
and if you wouldn't go
buy it right now for 450 that means you
should sell it for 450 doesn't it
yeah definitely okay i see what you're
saying yeah i mean it's
you know it's only like i said 1400
square feet i mean it just it just
ballooned florida is crazy right yeah so
and it was
crazy down just a few years smart
decision yeah i mean right after a
hurricane or right after 2008 it's crazy
down and you can't
you know you can't give stuff away down
there they have entire condominium
projects just sitting like
the wind is blowing through them when
times are bad but then when times are
like they are now
i mean it's the any old dump will sell
it's crazy
so and obviously you don't have a dump
you've obviously got a sweet little
house there
so very cool way to go pastor proud of
you man you've done a great job handling
your money and building wealth
i would cash out based on what you told
me if i were in your shoes
and those are the reasons so folks you
can always do that reverse
engineering thing it's called a sunk
cost analysis if i didn't own it and
instead i had that pile of money sitting
in the table
in front of me on the table in front of
me would i go buy it
you can do that with a boat looking at
the boat in the driveway
i could sell it for ten thousand dollars
okay get ten thousand dollars in the
middle of the table if you didn't have
a boat would you take that ten thousand
dollars off the table and go buy a boat
no i haven't used the stupid thing in
three years
okay then that means it's time to sell
the boat son you know you reverse
engineer the whole thing right
or the other way around you go uh if you
know if i didn't have a boat would i go
buy one yes i'd go buy one our family
uses it every weekend it's
where our family loves going the lake
and by the way that's the ramses we love
going the lake and so
uh you know that kind of thing so yeah
you would keep it then
because you'd buy it again and uh
you know you just have to ask yourself
that question if somebody put that much
money in front of you would you go buy
that item again
you can do it with an investment you
know and what it keeps you from doing is
like you bought something it
you bought an investment a stock at 70 a
share and it's down to 50.
and you go i'm gonna wait on it to come
back up although i don't really think
it's gonna come back up
how's that logical if you you know if
you wouldn't buy the shares at fifty
dollars because of what you know now
then sell them at fifty dollars and get
out regardless of what you paid for
what you paid for them is not relevant
it's what you think is gonna happen in
the future that's relevant
and that analysis makes you think
through a future lens
a sunk cost analysis reverse engineer
the process
great decision making tool this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
the ramsay show.com
thanks for listening
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions
broadcasting from the dollar car rental
studios it's
the ramsey show where debt is dumb cash
is king and the paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host flying solo
today ramsey personalities are all out
working not a bad thing
oh so here i am hanging out with you
guys open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight
eight two five five two two five anita
is with us in pensacola to start off
this hour hi anita how are you
hi i'm fine thank you very much good how
can i help
uh well here's here's the little rundown
on it
my husband and i are 65 and we hope to
retire
in about five years we're we're planning
to work until
70 or if one of us should get disabled
and we would retire then
but we are out of debt we have our
emergency fund
and 15 is going into retirement good
right now
good uh we're at a point that we were
thinking
uh to go ahead and start paying off the
house
good but here's the thing
since we only have about five years to
go
and i i don't know i haven't looked at
the at the figures just
in the last little while uh last year
when we met with the smart investor pro
we had a little bit less than a hundred
thousand
i mean 200 000 in retirement but that
was
just as we were starting the 15
so at this point we don't know we have a
like i said we have a small mortgage and
it's at 4.875
in other words four and seven eight um
so we're trying to determine whether we
should just
start putting all that extra into
retirement or
paying off the house uh you should put
15
of your income away and everything else
you can find in your budget you used to
pay off your small mortgage what's your
household income
uh about 75 000 between the two of you
right okay and how much is the mortgage
balance
the mortgage balance is about 63 000.
okay all right and so
uh if we really lean on this mortgage
because it's an emergency because it
kind of is
uh if you if you paid you said
63 000 right right you make
75. so 31
where 32 would pay a year would pay it
off in two years
21 would pay it off in three years
okay so sounds like two thousand dollars
a month on the mortgage
while you're putting at least fifteen
percent away now that puts you in three
years that puts you three years later
your house is paid off
because here's the thing okay you need
both going into retirement and let me
walk you through why you need a paid for
house and a nest egg
because a paid for a house is your your
housing is your most expensive line item
in your budget
if you don't have it paid for if it's re
if you're renting it goes up every year
while you
try to live from 70 to 90 over 20 years
your rent's gonna go through the roof
so number one you own number two you get
it paid
off and then you've gotten rid of
the biggest item on your budget your
house payment okay
okay so you've stabilized your golden
years
by getting the house paid off and then
of course we need this stuff like
food and electricity and gas for the car
and that means we need to have money
coming in from retirement which is the
nest egg side
and so right you know but i think you're
going to be fine here here's let's run
some numbers out
let's say you did 21 000 a year uh or
you did 2 000
a month you can do that you're just
going to get on a tight budget and watch
what you're doing because this is
important
that sounds tough it's very tight it's
very tight tighter than you've ever
lived on
i know that because you don't have any
money much and you're 65.
no so it's time for you time for you to
tighten the screws up it's college
i i know but here we are today it's time
for you you
you got to do this now there can't be
any more reasons there can't be more
reasons you got to do it
so two thousand dollars a month put you
out of debt in
under three years slightly under three
years
okay okay and now the 200 000 you said
was two years ago
uh well about a year and a half ago okay
if you didn't add anything to that and
you will be
that 200 000 will double about every
seven years
if your mutual funds are earning around
10 or more
and they should be okay so
200 is going to be 400 when you're 70.
okay because there's two years ago seven
years to 70 right
right so that's 400 plus you're gonna be
putting in
another thousand dollars a month which
is twelve thousand dollars a year which
is fifteen percent of your income
into retirement and you've already been
doing that so you've already got a
little more
and you're going to be doing that for
the entire five years oh wait no
you're gonna be doing that only for
under three years and then there's no
house payments so now you can go to two
thousand dollars a month going into nest
egg
oh okay and two thousand dollars a month
twenty four thousand a year
plus twelve thousand a year for three
years
there's another fifty thousand bucks
plus what it grows
okay so by 70. by 70 you should have
six seven hundred thousand bucks in a
paid for house if you do exactly what i
told you
but if you go screwing around and keep
messing with this and coming up with
excuses you're gonna have a mess so you
need to act like your hair is on fire
for the next three years
two thousand dollars a month plus a
thousand dollars a month into retirement
that's three thousand dollars a month by
the way three thousand dollars thirty
six
thousand out of seventy five thousand
that leaves you that leaves you enough
to live on
okay but you ain't living large you're
living small
no no so we never have lived large yeah
so that you can have some golden years
from 70 and on
right okay yeah this is this is within
your reach
the math says you can do it now
personal finance is 80 behavior it's
only 20 head knowledge
we just gave you the 20 head knowledge
now you got to go do the behaviors
which by the way is the hard part i mean
the math of becoming wealthy is not hard
it's sixth grade math
but nobody does it so hey good question
thank you for joining us
here's what's interesting if your mutual
funds average 12 percent which the stock
market has averaged a
little over 11 and a half since it began
so if your mutual fund slightly
outperformed the market and you made 12
and you put a hundred dollars a month
away from age 25 to age 65
100
pizza breath you spend that on pizza
dollars a 100.00 every month
from age 25 to 65 is 1 million 176 000
everyone in america should retire
millionaire
if you grasp that knowledge oh wait
you have to do the behavior oh there's
the problem
the idiot in my mirror is a problem
child
if i could get this guy to behave he'd
be skinny and rich
but he's got issues the behavior people
it's the behavior it's not the math the
math is not hard
we make enough money in this country to
be wealthy
but it's controlling our little selves
me too baby that's the problem
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
have you ever considered how your
spending habits
influence your kids
rachel cruz says in our book smart money
smart kids that more is caught than
taught
if the way you medicate stress is you go
shopping
and you laughingly call it retail
therapy as if that's harmless
guess what your teenage daughter just
watched you
and as soon as she feels stressed she's
gonna do what
daddy did or mommy did
so you gotta get you want your kids to
turn out you gotta turn out
that's the first thing and and also you
got to teach them we've dropped our
prices up to 80
on our best-selling kids products so you
can have a fun
and educational summer the adventure
pack is a family favorite for the little
guys
it includes the story time collection
with junior from financial peace junior
the actual financial peace junior kit
which teaches you how to teach kids how
to handle money
the smart saver bank and also if you've
got teens the
anthony o'neill's teen entrepreneur
toolbox is the perfect
safe and flexible way for them to create
their own business
as their summer job so it's a kids and
teen sale up to 80
off in the store at ramseysolutions.com
be sure and check out the store right
now
at ramseysolutions.com our question of
the day comes from blinds.com they have
a
100 satisfaction guarantee even if you
mismeasure
you pick the wrong color have you ever
screwed something up like that
like you you go to home depot and you
buy the thing it doesn't fit
like every time gosh i'm sorry
am i venting here well they have they
have a guarantee at blinds.com that when
you do that
they will give you a new blind
free if you mess it up i mean who does
that companies that are great
like blinds.com i've been endorsing this
company a long
time and the reason is they're
incredible use the promo code ramsey
when you go there
you can save all kinds of money today's
question my husband and i
are 27 years and 28 years old we each
have our own small businesses recently
began our debt-free journey
we're in baby step two getting out of
debt and not investing i'm wondering
what is the benefit of investing into a
retirement account
that you can't touch until retirement
age as opposed to other mutual funds
with similar growth that you can access
more freely taxes
let me explain to you let's say you know
right before the break i said if you put
i mean 100 100
a month away uh from age 25 to 65 you'd
have 1 million 176 000
if you put 2 away you'd have 2.2 million
2.4 million
okay so 200 bucks which for most of you
once you're out of debt and have your
emergency fund doesn't even
even equal as much as you should be
which is 15
of your income but let's just use two
million dollars you get to retirement
casey and you
have been taxed all these years
on all of that money
as it has grown and so in other words
for you to end up
when you would have ended up with 2.2
million dollars for 200
a month during the in that example you
would have ended up with
a million dollars okay
let's say you put it into a roth ira
now 200 a month is 2400
a year for 40 years is like
80 grand 100 grand okay
but there's two million dollars in there
you put in 100 grand
the rest of the money from 100 up to 2.2
so 2.1 million dollars is growth
on the account if it's in a roth there
is zero taxes on the growth
if it's in a traditional ira or in a
mutual fund
as you would know out retirement
protection a hundred percent of the
growth is taxed when it comes out
if you pay taxes on 2.1 million dollars
it's gonna sound suspiciously like five
or six hundred thousand dollars
so this word roth in this one example
where you're only saving 200
a month which is not much this word roth
is worth around
six hundred thousand dollars
so this i want access to because i might
wanna buy something
cost you six hundred thousand dollars
okay so no you you you do roth iras
first and foremost when you get to baby
step four
because the tax-free growth and the fact
that the vast majority of what is in
your account when you get to retirement
is growth
only a hundred thousand out of the 2.2
in that example
was principal the rest of it was growth
and zero taxes on the growth is a six
hundred thousand
per two hundred thousand dollar
discussion a per two million dollar
discussion
so it's a lot of freaking money
in order to have access to it now here's
what's interesting though casey when you
start saving 15
of your income and you have no debt and
you start doing baby step 5 and putting
your kids college fund away and baby
step 6 you get your house paid off
oh then we can start investing more and
some of that will be money that you have
access to
i'm not 65. i just turned 60 this year
and i've never touched my retirement
accounts and i've done
tons of other side investing because
i've been out of debt for 30 freaking
years
and you can save invest a lot of money
in addition to your retirement if you
just saved a house payment
so that's what changes the entire
equation right there so it's a big deal
it's a big big deal
antonio is with us in charlotte north
carolina hey antonio what's up in your
world
hey dave how are you can you hear me
okay absolutely sir how can we help
um i'm happy i found you about a year
and a half ago
i feel like i made a kind of terrible
terrible decision
i was down to my last two deaths i'm on
baby step two
i had a personal loan
with about five fifty three hundred left
and a
car loan that was about fifty three
hundred left my car was giving me a lot
of issues
i had gotten a lot of work done to it
and so i decided to
ideally gave me an offer more than the
blue book value board
so i kind of took that money and
the money they paid off the rest of the
car um i took that money and
um paid off the personal loan um so now
i'm
you know i was left with you know the
money i was left with instead of going
out and buying a
uh four or five thousand dollar car um i
decided
to go to the dealership and i bought a
used
uh 2014 ford escape about
28 000 miles on it um
i financed it which was a terrible idea
and now i just feel it's the only debt
that i have
um now but i just i just feel terrible
getting into a
finance car for another five years
um interest rate in about a four hundred
dollar car payment
six percent interest rate in the 400 car
payment so
i just wanted to know your thoughts if i
should i got it a week ago
just wanted to know if you know if you
think it's worth keeping with it being
my only debt now
and just paying off as fast as possible
or
try to try to sell it
sounds like you need to give up drinking
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm kidding but you woke up with a
serious financial hangover didn't you
yeah absolutely terrible decision yeah
so you either go back out partying again
tonight
or you avoid the alcohol because you
gave you a hangover
translation you sell a stupid car dude
yes sir i mean you knew that right i
didn't have to tell you that you just
want me to say it out loud for you
i i i i believe so i i felt terrible
about it every time
i'm not going to shame you because i've
done dumber stuff but the trick is
here's the thing what i try to do when i
do something stupid and man i have paid
so much stupid text in my life
i have a phd in dumb man i have done so
many stupid butt stuff
i've done stuff that makes you look like
a genius okay
and you're not okay
[Applause]
but uh so i mean it's okay we've all
been there there's a point now the
question is this
i always ask myself when i do something
stupid and it leaves a mark like this
where i like
oh crap that was so dumb you know what
i'm saying
i try to like mark that down in my
stupid book
because i'm gonna do something else
stupid i know i am
but i just try not to do the same stupid
thing again
right and what you did here was you
repeated a stupid thing
because you got a car payment in the
first place and you went and traded it
for a different car payment that was
bigger
which is obviously perpendicular to your
goal of being out of debt so
the big lesson here is you looking in
the mirror and going
i'm going to get control of you
that's the big thing you do what you
want to do brother i'm not here to beat
you up i've done dumber like i said but
if i woke up in your shoes i'd sell that
car
this week and then stay off the car lot
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
wayne and sherry are with us hey guys
how are you
very well how are you very welcome
welcome where do you guys live we live
in
kingsport tennessee oh yeah awesome well
welcome to nashville
and all the way over here to do a
debt-free scream how much did you pay
off
we paid off 131 000
and it took us four years good for you
and your range of income during that
time
80 to 110. okay cool what do y'all do
for a living
i work for eastman chemical and i just
retired
at early retirement i just i love it yes
retired from what what did you do i had
a small dog grooming business
okay because you don't look like a
retiree to me
really i'm not but i just done it anyway
i like it
very very good good for you what kind of
debt was the 131 thousand
we had some a couple of vehicle payments
a pool loan and credit cards oh okay is
she kind of normal
mm-hmm that's all right how long have
you guys been married almost 24 years
it'll be 24 years in september okay
what happened at the 20-year mark four
years ago that made you decide
we're cleaning this up it hit me when i
was 40. i didn't want to
do it no more huh 40 year old birthday
was a wake-up call it was it really was
i was wasn't getting any younger and we
had a lot of stuff
but we had no money and we was tired of
living that way so
make plenty of money and don't have any
exactly just like working for everybody
else
it just hit us at the same time we was
just ready to do it and get it done
so what did you do how did you connect
to us and what's the story we
sat down and tried to do a budget on our
own and it wasn't working
and i was at my brother's house and his
wife linda
mentioned your name yeah so we we went
uh got home that night got on youtube
and seen some dave ramsey rants
and we were hooked so we
so we uh signed up for financial peace
university oh wow
and our first budget we was in the
negative
i don't know i don't know how we made it
i would borrow from one credit card to
make the payment on another credit yeah
yeah done that and it
it was over dave it just couldn't live
like this anymore enough
enough you really disgusted and said
disgusted yes
absolutely and i after we attacked a
smallest death
it was a qvc debit card
that was mine that was hers and i can
remember
one night she was doing the budget and
woke me up and said we are in the green
it was seven dollars to the green but it
was a great feeling
but we didn't owe more than
yeah then we was making so and after
that
we wore it out yeah we just came on
turned up the dog grooming turned up the
overtime turned and turned down the
spending and here we go sold my purse
collection
oh yeah that was hard at the beginning
but it worked how much did your purse
collection sell for
about it was under three thousand but it
was about maybe twenty five twenty eight
hundred dollars
girl you had some purses i had about 50.
well you just needed your life back
anyway that was my stuff that was my
stuff
wow good for you that's fun that's fun
so you uh what do you tell people the
key to getting out of that is
budgeting absolutely budgeting use your
envelope system stuff it full of cash
and when it's empty it's empty you don't
go use your
well of course you don't get your credit
cards but don't use your debit cards
even
when your envelopes are empty you're
done go home
go home we stopped worrying about
everybody else too
what other people think right yeah it's
almost impossible to win financially
when you worry about what other people
think it is that's what we just don't
know a lot of
there's a lot of pressure there that's
interesting very cool
yeah you guys had a complete uh complete
redo here this is very cool
so uh when you're going through
financial peace university
nine weeks nine different classes
which one of those classes did you go oh
i knew this and now i'm gonna go do it
pretty much all of them it was just like
a wake-up call we were like what were we
doing
and then we would go to one of your
classes and we're like ah yeah
do that what about you wayne
the the budgeting part was really what
that was the one that's okay
yes sir all right yeah you're getting
that stuff under control
very good well done guys very well done
so in 24 years of marriage you spent the
last four years getting out of debt is
this the only time you've been debt-free
in 24 years
yes only time okay only time i'm proud
of you
thank you very proud of you will you
ever go back absolutely not
no not living like that never good
answer and i hope our kids follow in our
footsteps
now not in the past right now start
right now yeah we're going to start you
on this tomorrow
wow well way to go you guys who were
your biggest cheerleaders outside the
two of you
uh my mom and dad yeah they they pushed
us a lot
okay and our three girl we have three
daughters and
linda linda's got to be cheering well
yes
she's she's kind of the starting point
she was she was
yeah that's neat that's a that's a a
neat testimony for her
yeah yeah so well done you guys well
done well we've got a copy of the legacy
journey for you
uh that's the next stage in your uh
walk here as you become wealthy because
you are heading that way now
no payments and now you have control and
now you have conviction and
now you've got common sense and man
you're ready to go can i say one thing
the only the only argument we have about
money now is
which savings account we want to put it
in so
[Laughter]
yeah that's that's pretty good argument
there's worse arguments to have that's
for sure
that's great very good all right
we've also got a copy of the total money
makeover for you so you can give it to
someone pay it forward and
uh maybe start their journey maybe
you're somebody's lynda and i
get things going yes way to go you two
wayne
and sherry from kingsport 131 000 paid
off in four years
making 80 to 110. count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
three two one we're not free
[Music]
[Applause]
that is it baby that's it
hey if you guys want to plug into
financial peace university
like they did you can do it you don't
have to live like you're living
you can stop going in circles you can
start making progress
check out ramsey plus the membership
will show you how to make the changes
you need to get the results you want
gives you complete access to financial
peace university to every dollar premium
teaches you how to do the envelopes like
she's talking about i mean we're going
to walk you we've got community there
for you to plug in get
support and encouragement accountability
we got coaches you can plug into
all of this is in ramsey plus and you
can get a
free trial for ramsey plus right now
what's the downside of a free trial no
downside you got to get in there and
look at it and
you know you can go in there watch
financial peace university start
watching it tonight
you know it's that easy so start making
real progress
free trial what you do is you text trial
to 33 789
text trial two three three
seven eight nine
you know what's interesting in their
case
that applies to you yeah i'm talking to
you
nothing changed in their life
they just woke up and decided
no more there was no big
job crisis there was no big medical
crisis
there was no big
i turned 40 and i'm not living like this
anymore that's all it was
and sometimes you you have to get
disgusted with yourself to change
something you know what i mean
you got to get a little bit pissed off
at yourself and go self you're stupid
self you have to stop this see i just
did that
because what i do when i get when i'm
working like a maniac and i'm working a
bazillion hours which is what i was
doing doing kova to try to keep this
place open
i was working 100 hours down here man
and we were i lived down here just about
me and the leadership team were trying
to keep these thousand people paid
and keep the revenue turned and we're
pivoting
and unprecedented and all that bs that
we all just went through in the last
year
and what i did was i ate everything in
sight
i mean there wasn't a chocolate donut
left within a 50-mile radius of me
i sucked them all down i got so
fat it was disgusting
and i looked in the mirror and i went
you're disgusting
so since i got disgusted i lost 37
pounds see
you can just decide okay you can just
decide
look stupid stop it you can just decide
that that's what i did and it's what
they did
and it's you know we all we all screw up
the question is are you going to live
like that
no stop it this
is the ramsey shop
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
common sense for your dollars and cents
it's the ramsey show
proving that common sense is like having
a superpower
eric is with us eric is in san antonio
hey eric what's up
hey dave how you doing first time caller
here
got a question for you about um career
okay
so effectively i'm i'm in a role as a
business analyst and i'm kind of i'm
kind of trying to exit this
career field and become a financial
advisor i just find that that's what
gives me the most
joy uh dopamine surges in life is
helping people with their finances
um that being that being said my wife
and i are still in baby step two
we're down from about a hundred thousand
to forty thousand remaining we
got a bit to go we just recently had a
baby
so our income has been cut just to my
income
at about sixty thousand but that being
said i um
i have this home who reached out to me
with an opportunity
uh it's again a business analyst role
for about a hundred thousand
um i just wonder you know if i should
take it even though i'm trying to exit
this arena
um you know just to get that
increase in and pay be debt free in a
year flat
and then move on with my career
aspirations or if i should not be
pursuing something
that is not in line with my long-term
goals
uh so so uh if you move to
a financial advisor what do you make
you know i think it largely determined
it's largely determined by
the um the commission that i would be
able to
uh to learn um i think starting out from
what i've seen
it can range from 60 on up through
i mean theoretically sky's the limit i
mean if you're just going to be a
you know just just a total superstar i
mean you can read quite a bit
um so it you know i think starting out
it may be comparable though
to what i'm meaning now okay comparable
except that it has upside
based on your performance correct yes
sir
and it's in and it's doing what you love
idea
yes well go do that
right so you would not take the uh go do
that and make a hundred
60 60 is your downside
if you go do that and you make 70 or 80
versus taking 100 and then you turn
around walk back out on those people
who hired you a year later
that's kind of why no i'm until you do
that i
i should clarify it was it's a contract
it was a one-year contract
so it's like i i would kind of have the
red carpet on the way out
really you know because it's a one-year
contract i i thought that would have
been tacky too if i just quit after yeah
okay that's helpful that's helpful
information
that makes me more tempted to do it but
i tell you what i would do i would sit
down with your financial advising firm
that you're talking about going with
and say okay i got this i got this
carpet ride for a year for 100.
i got a brand new baby my wife's off i
can knock out my debt doing that
but if i can see my way to making 100
here if you can show me what it takes to
do that and i can believe i can do it
i'll probably just come do that
okay and if not if not i'll probably see
you in a year
right right okay you kind of use it as a
leverage so
if they say if they say look the top uh
the top three percent of people hired
into this role
go you know they don't make 60 they make
100 the first year
don't do it take the carpet ride but if
they say
you know half our guys make 100 the
first year
well surely god you can get in the top
half
yeah i would hope so you know that's
what i'm you know that's the way i'm
looking at it that's why i would look at
it if it was me
doing it i just go you know i think i
can get in the top half i don't know if
i can get in the top three percent i may
not be that smart
or or may not work as hard or i may not
have the golden touch i don't know
whatever
three percent would bother me but but if
there's a it's a 50
of the people that try this can do it
and make 100 first year then i'm i'm
dude i'm doing what i love
because you have a high probability of
doing what you love of earning more
right
so right either way 12 months 12 months
from now you're doing it right
right you know that's that's my goal
unless some unforeseen event comes in
and i
just fell in love all over again with
business analysis which i just don't
know
yeah i don't think that's gonna happen
um so what what runs through my head is
if you call me up and said i make 60 and
i got a part-time job offer for 40
uh or i can quit my job and go make 60
and not have the part-time job i i you
know
and i hate the part-time job i would
tell you go do the part-time job
and get out of debt for a year you got a
baby clear your debt up and get yourself
going right
and in a sense that's kind of what we're
doing we're taking a one-year part-time
job
that's 40 over what you're being paid on
contract and
it's okay to be on contract because
you're bailing anyway 12 months from now
to go into the advisor side of the world
because that's what gives you the juice
right
yeah so it sounds like from from what
you're saying that there's
depending on the numbers and the
circumstances either of these
decisions could work out being the the
wiser choice there's not one
if you've got a reasonable probability
that you think you can hit without being
ego based or
weird you know of hitting it at advisor
go do it as an advisor but if the
probability is very small like almost
none of our guys make 100 the first year
go take the hundred do it for a year
clean it up do it for your young family
that's like working an extra job it's
one year it's one year you can do
anything for a year
and and then you're done but yeah just
talk talk it through with your the
company you're talking about going on
with us
with as an advisor i think they can give
you real numbers
and if they're just trying to blow smoke
then you know you got to get somebody to
really tell you what's really going on
in that world
i don't know is the answer from me i i
don't know what you can do there
or what their commission structure is or
how they pay they may say
no you're not allowed to do anything
that increases your income you're locked
at 60 for the first 12. oh well in that
case i'm for sure taking this carpet
ride
ashley's with us in las vegas hi ashley
how are you
hi thank you for having me i'm good good
how can i help
so we decided to sell our home because
we're kind of in a pickle
um the market's good for selling our
home but our question is kind of what do
we do with the equity afterwards my
husband and i have split stock
what's the pickle so
i so i started doing real estate and i
dropped my job completely that i had
well i didn't really have a job since
covid
i was in the serving industry and then
my husband has a job where he makes
about 600 a week
and then our mortgage is over i want to
say is 13
a month which isn't a bad mortgage but
we kind of just can't keep up with all
of our bills we're about
40 grand in debt um 24 credit card
20 for cars and motorcycle
and our best option really is to sell
our home i am getting another job right
now to be on top of real estate
um but we're unable to kind of figure
out anything
i guess would be almost like a quick fix
kind of deal how much do you owe on your
motorcycle
six grand what do you owe on the cars
you said 20 total right
yeah i want to say it was it might be a
little more than 20 for everything to do
together it might be about 18 or 17. on
the car
yes a car yes
okay you have a car you can't afford
that you need to sell
and a motorcycle you need to sell
believe me if i could get rid of those
two things
um yeah that would have been my first
choice and i that is your first choice
yeah you can go home under we have our
home under contract
um why are you calling me then you're
already
doing what you're doing what you're
gonna do no no the question i have is
so we have we'll have equity afterwards
yeah sell the motorcycle and sell the
car
afterwards right and use the equity to
pay off all the other stuff
and get yourself situated with an
emergency fund and get your career
straightened out
because your problem has been an income
problem and you
keep buying crap you can't afford right
and so if you stop if you fix the income
problem and get rid of the toys that you
bought that you can't afford
then you position yourself to make some
leaps forward
but otherwise the home equity is going
to go to pay for stupidity
right so after everything said and done
even after paying off our debts
we'll still be out about 120 000
that's how much we're taking oh wow
that's wonderful
yeah we're going to have a pretty that's
after paying off my grandmother she
loved us 50 grand for the home loan
originally yeah so yeah clear off all
debts then
and get you a paid for car and get your
career going get settled into the career
rent something
park the money in a savings account in a
money market account for one year
while you save up even more and you get
your career stabilized before you
repurchase
and you do all of that debt free with an
emergency fund in place and you'll have
a good down payment
yeah that's what you're doing but you
need to sell the car and the motorcycle
they're ridiculous
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker
just tell alexa google assistant or siri
to play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting
from the dollar car rental studios it's
the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host thank you for joining
us america
this is your show where we talk about
you right in front of you
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five matt is in lancaster
pennsylvania hi
matt how are you good how you doing dave
better than i deserve what's up
awesome uh first i just want to say
thank you uh in 2015
uh me and my wife found you and paid off
120 000
uh in 2018 so thank you for that good
for you
yeah look forward to seeing you when the
mortgages paid off um
currently uh i'm a nurse at a hospital
in lancaster that is going to be
mandating uh the covert vaccine
which i'm not sure if i'm going to get
it yet so i'm looking at
possibly doing a career change we have
an 18 month old
and our second baby is due
august 24th if i don't get the vaccine
it would be my firing date would be
september first
we're in baby steps four five and six we
have about
uh fifty five thousand in retirement
with my work
um we both have iras that have about
three thousand
each we're putting in money for our
first child's college fund
uh monthly and we're putting about four
hundred dollars extra
on the mortgage uh so i guess my
question is how much is in the emergency
fund
uh the emergency fund right now has
fifteen thousand dollars
and what's your household income uh
i bring home gross about 63 and then
take home from my wife she intern
business she's bringing
around like a thousand to hundred a
month take home
i don't know what her gross is okay but
we would probably bring home
about 4 500 a month
okay so august
july in the rest of june
so you've got 75 days
correct yep okay
all right um for them to either change
their mind or you get
a different nursing job why don't you
just get a different nursing job
um it's a shortage
two i know um so the
thinking is that's possibility um so i'm
really into finances after
discovering you um and i have been in
talks with my financial advisor about
uh becoming a financial advisor myself
if that's all through
and i'm also looking at other nursing
jobs uh the only
issue that i see with that is it's one
of the largest companies
hospital-wide um in pennsylvania um on
the philadelphia side and i
believe everyone's kind of just watching
to see
how many nurses and people leave well
that's happening that's happening
everywhere
okay yeah and the point is and you
you're well aware of this i don't need
to tell you this
but i'm just going to remind you of what
you already know they have there's a lot
of places that have nurses that are not
hospitals yeah
that's true yeah so i guess i could do
that
yeah yeah because here's the thing
here's the thing you need to make the
jump to financial advisor from strength
not desperation and weakness and yeah so
that's my
i also yeah so i've been offered from
other people
that know that i'm in to finances and
stuff they
have talked to me about training me to
be an accountant and stuff like that and
i don't want to that's what me and my
wife have discussed i don't want to be
taking any kind of job
out of desperation just kind of like
listening to you and stuff like that
yeah i think you need to finish out
getting real clear on what this next
move from nursing
is and you need to make the jump from
nursing
um so what i think is going to happen is
i think you're going to find another
nursing job in the next three weeks
okay because you're actually going to
start looking
yeah do you think no do you think i
should wait
like say my start date would be in
september
no i think i think if these bozos are
willing to put you on the street i'm
willing to put them on the street
okay that's kind of my feeling too do
you think um
now with that would you stop investing
because we're investing 15
no i think i'd go get a job making more
than i make now
and quit the bad job with the bad people
okay all right so here's what's
happening okay
you're this is happening all over
america
yeah you know we're we've got large
companies
mandating vaccines and people are
leaving them in
droves okay so hospitals i've talked to
uh 20 people in healthcare in the past
three or four weeks
and what's happening is that they're
doing stuff like they're talking about
doing with you and and
the nurses are saying uh uh i'm not
taking this thing
i'm out i i listen i'm not signing up
so then what happens is they take where
they've already got a nursing shortage
at that hospital
and they exasperate it and then they're
once they once they make the decision
then they go back and undo the decision
because they realize how
screwed they are because half their
people walk out it's like causing a
strike
yeah and that's what's kind of going on
here yeah i got a feeling as soon as you
find a job
they're going to change their mind yeah
but i'm not sure i want to stay there
anyway if they're if they're willing to
put the muscle on me like that
yeah that's so again being in the
financial situation we are thanks to you
guys
um i feel like i can leave well
definitely a lot of my co-workers that
feel yeah you can leave because you can
go make more
yeah because you're in you're in a
fabulous field nursing is a fabulous
field you
you know you're only as secure not as
some company providing you security
you're only as secure as your ability to
go land another thing doing it
and nursing you can always land another
thing doing it so you've got security
because of your knowledge base and
because of your licensing
and and because of your willingness to
do what you do and thank you for doing
it by the way
but um yeah i had a friend of mine the
other day he's working for a huge
corporation he'd been there for years
and he was going to retire in two years
and they said you have to have a vaccine
to
come back into the office and he said
okay i'll just retire now
and he's one of their top sales guys and
they lost him
you people in corporate america are
idiots y'all are idiots
you're just dumb it's unbelievable and
it has nothing to do with you really
think somebody's going to get sick
you're just virtue signaling
you just want to look like i'm sensitive
you're not sensitive you're corporate
america you're idiots
you treat a guy like this who's been
serving people
like a slab of meat and you know what
he's going to do he's going to
walk on you that's what he's going to do
and that's what you deserve
golly unbelievable look if you want to
take a vaccine i'm not mad at you but
somebody
mandating that you have to do that or
you lose your
job a they deserve to lose the talent
they deserve for talent to turn on their
heel and walk out the door wire
see around ramsey we got a rule we don't
have a rule
[Laughter]
you can wear a mask if you want to you
don't have to wear a mask if you don't
want to
you can take your temperature at the
door if you want to or you cannot take
your temperature at the door if you want
to
and everybody's getting along and nobody
died
hitting this is a wonderful thing and
just but just don't be
pissing and telling everybody else how
they got to live
a bunch of people telling everybody else
how they got to live it's a debt
mind your own business this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 dollars
a month by switching
to pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save
50 off your first month pure talk
simply smarter wireless
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the cost of college has gotten very
real serious dollars especially if
you're going to a four-year school right
you need a plan to pay for college
you got some littles you want your
littlest to go to school
you need to plan baby an esa an
educational savings account
a 529 they're both places that you can
invest
after tax dollars and they grow tax
free age and income restrictions on the
investment options you're given are a
little bit different
and to get a better understanding of the
choices that are right for you
you need to talk with a real expert
financial advisor someone with the heart
of a teacher text
the word invest to 33 789
and we'll connect you with one of our
smartmister pros that we have vetted
they're trustworthy they will guide you
and you will make your decisions about
getting your college plan started for
your little
invest text invest to thirty three
seven eight nine invest two thirty three
seven eight nine and we'll hook you up
with the smartvestor pro
blaine is in tacoma hi blaine welcome to
the ramsay show
hey dave it's truly an honor to speak
with you you too what's up
hey sir so um i had a question
concerning
how do i best navigate the baby steps
in regards to purchasing a home i am
active duty military
i've been in for 12 years no debt
i've got the fully funded emergency fund
and i've been saving for a down payment
for a home
a little over two years um i've got
uh just over 20 000 saved
um you know but i'm looking at at least
eight years
before i'm ready to purchase a home as
i'm going to be moving
every couple of years so i guess i
wanted to get your thoughts on
am i should i do the all cash down
approach is that the best way
yeah just start just throw that that 20
grand into a mutual fund
uh get you can get something like an
index fund uh which is like an s p 500
it'll have no commission on it
and there'll be no taxes on the growth
until you pull it out
if you leave it alone or hardly any
taxes maybe tiny bit
um because it's got a low turnover ratio
and then just keep piling money in there
and that's
the i'm going to buy a house for cash
when i get out of the military fund
now am i while doing that um am i
still investing in retirement yeah so
i'd be putting 15
of your income into retirement while
you're doing that this is like your baby
step
six it's like paying off your house
early okay
so baby step four is fifteen percent of
your income going over time at five is
kids college
and six is pay off your house early so
money that you would normally if you
owned a house you'd be
with a mortgage on you'd be chunking
above the 15 above the kids college
you'd be chunking money on there to get
rid of that house mortgage as fast as
you can
okay okay so do my so do my minimum 15
treat my down payment for a house as if
it were a mortgage
and just follow the steps uh you know in
that order then
yep pile up the cash man
thank you for your service we appreciate
you open phones at triple eight eight
two five
five two two five jason is in san
francisco hi jason how are you
oh not too bad how about yourself dave
better than i deserve what's up all
right so my question's
somewhat similar uh to the previous
caller um
and that i am also planning to buy a
house in the next one to five years
um i have a
401k with my previous employer
uh there's about 145 000 in there right
now
um i'm contemplating or i'm going to
roll that over into an ira account
um i'm contemplating if i should put
that
into a raw ira or a traditional eye
right now
no because it's going to cost you 40
grand in taxes
correct so that's that was my question
so i have no debt
um i have about of my own own savings i
have 190
190 000 in my uh currently in between my
brokerage account and my roth ira
um 15k net uh
nest egg um and then i and then i maxed
out my 401k my roth ira every year
you're killing it you're killing it
where'd it go thank you um my parents
have given me 250
000 to essentially buy or support
help buy a home um that currently right
now i have as
cash so i could take
yeah me too right so i can take some of
that money
to pay the taxes if i convert no i would
only do that after your home is paid for
and you're not going to have a paid for
home you call me from san francisco
well that was my thing so i'm not going
to buy a house in the bay area or in
california i will for sure move out of
here before i do that i don't know
when and where i know within the next
five years but the housing market's high
right now and
i have to get that plan figured out so
this part
just park it in a money market or a
mutual fund or some combo of the two
while you make that decision but either
way it's a down payment or the ability
to pay cash for a home
if you move to a much cheaper area to
buy a home right
and i don't want you i don't want you
messing up up
uh the down payment or the the killer
thing on the home
uh by having to pay taxes on the roth
you can always go you can always flip it
from a traditional to a roth later
so here let me let me walk you through
here here's what i think you should do
when you flip 140 000 to a roth
and it activates 35 or 40 000 in taxes
that's like investing 35 or 40 000
more into your retirement account
effectively mathematically
does that make sense yeah and i would
only want you to do that
at baby step seven
gotcha after i have the home exactly and
the homes paid off
because if i got to choose between
investing more or
than 15 or paying off the home well
that's not our steps paying off the
homes baby step six
and so that's how i'm working this
through from a critical thinking so i'm
making this decision while i'm talking
to you is
i'm treating you like you need to flip
this to seven
you need to flip this to a roth when you
get to baby step seven and you have the
extra cash to pay the taxes it creates
gotcha gotcha okay so anything that
impedes you being at baby step seven
is is in the wrong order and so that
that's that's
that's how i'm working this through in
my head hey man thanks for the call
you are too and man oh make sure mom and
dad got some tax advice
because you can't give somebody 250
thousand dollars you can give them 15
000
without if tax being activated at 55
percent
you don't want gift tax there is a way
they can do it but they need to get
professional tax advice if they haven't
it's called a unified estate tax credit
and they have to do a filing with their
get in the year that they give you this
gift
um it's a wonderful gift but they need
to do it with intelligence otherwise
the tax man cometh and he always taketh
kelly is with us kelly is in
indianapolis hi kelly how are you
hi how are you dave better than i
deserve what's up
okay so this kind of just came to me
today um
but i'm really looking to start a side
hustle to try to cut through some of
this that i have i have around 6 000 in
debt
and i love photography i take pictures
of my son and all of my friends i've
thought about purchasing a really nice
camera
with my savings so i have 2100 in
savings right now
and the camera set is around 1200 for a
really good set
so i'm wondering if purchasing that set
to continue to bust through the set
faster while also replenishing my
savings would be smart
what kind of camera have you got now
i have a canon but it's not like a super
nice one i'm looking for i'm looking at
the nikon ds3500 right now
take your canon and go make a thousand
dollars with it
okay and use that thousand dollars
to buy the camera okay
so you know you haven't made any money
taking pictures yet you don't buy a 1200
camera set when you haven't made any
money making pictures yet
right i want you to this is called proof
texting
in business we put the we put the idea
out there and we make it
actually make money before we expand it
okay so how do you go about taking
you know upper level pictures with a
bottom level camera
oh now your cannon you can make a
thousand dollars with
okay nobody nobody is hiring you've
never done it before
no one's gonna hire a brand new beginner
for 150 000 and expect you to come in
with 300 000
worth of equipment they don't do that
they expect you to do what you're doing
and so yeah you
this is all about whether you got an eye
and whether you know how to handle this
equipment that you have or not
that's not the deal the equipment is not
the issue
you are the issue you are the secret
sauce in this formula
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
tj and amy are with us hey guys how are
you
great honor to be here thanks for having
us well we're honored to have you guys
where do you all live
california what part southern orange
county
oh yeah fun well good to have you guys
welcome welcome
i just talked to a pastor friend of mine
out there i'm going to come out and
speak in
september in irvine okay so well welcome
to nashville and all the way over here
to do a debt-free stream how much have
you paid off
39 000 all right and how long did that
take
10 months good for you and your range of
income during that time
we started at about 13 000 and got up to
160.
there's a story there yeah okay
so what kind of debt was the 39 000 hi
that was all me um yeah it was almost
my name yeah
i brought in all the debt to the
relationship and uh
it was actually her that was like yeah
we're going to take care of that
immediately okay i'm not living like
this and so you just got married i take
it
yes okay and how long ago a year okay
so immediately after you come home from
the honeymoon 10 months
boom we're knocking this out yes oh yeah
so uh what it was what kind of it was
you but was it student loans
all student loans okay all right cool
what's your degree uh business
good and what about yours education all
right fun fun
yeah okay so you're dating and you
discover he has this problem
yes pretty much we were in college
together so it was a conversation
yeah okay i knew i was getting into okay
before you
before you were even dating you knew yes
oh yeah okay so
uh but then when it starts getting
serious you she starts saying we're
doing this immediately
yeah um i mean my parents were doing
everything they could to help me out
through college but i still had
some debt coming out and uh
and she just basically told me uh this
needs to be handled
immediately and we're not moving forward
until it gets handled
and you're putting all of your fun
little hobbies kind of to the side and
you know we're crushing this cool and
you did you crushed it yeah i mean you
hammered it yeah so you came out of
school and both of you got jobs
and that's how you go from 13 to 160
yeah
kind of okay what's the kind of part so
it was a year after we got out of school
that we got married
so before that he's a professional
hockey player
so he had played in sweden and then by
the time we got married he was
unemployed in between seasons oh okay
and then covet hits and uh you know and
there's all hockey players are
unemployed
yeah pretty much i couldn't get back
overseas and
it got to a situation where you know
she's teaching online
and i'm training in the morning and not
working
and to cope with the stress of not
having a hockey job for the first time
in my life
i'm just spending money engulfing oh and
uh there it is after a couple months
which is what all hockey players do
right
exactly yeah and uh she sat me down and
was basically like uh
i'm doing everything here all the work
and you we gotta get a plan
we gotta get a plan going so so all the
nhl players i know
are really good golfers yeah by and
large i mean a few of them still try to
slap shot with a driver but
it's a fairly easy eye-hand connection
there yeah exactly
yeah good stuff so are you playing now
uh so i just signed back in sweden
a team called tiering soss which is
about three hours south of stockholm
uh in the meantime a guy that i know
through hockey for the past 10 years
he is a manager at tustin hyundai out in
california
so i was just kind of venting to him
when we were skating together of
if i don't get a job my wife might kill
me
that's not quite true but well that in
the golf right i'm spending money not
making money so he's like why don't you
just come sell cars and inside i'm
screaming
no because like that's just not what i
ever pictured myself doing
and i thought it's going to be a sketchy
business and then we
i go to tustin hyundai after a training
session
and i'm thinking i'm just going to see
the place i'm not going to commit to
anything and he had me in a flash
interview and hired
working tomorrow before i even left
there uh so i kind of
didn't really have that big of a choice
in it but uh ever since i got there it's
been absolutely amazing
and i i've loved the family there the
management's great the people are great
so
it's worked out not sketchy at all no
not even a little bit
good so how does the sweden thing work
are you commuting i mean
yeah we live there halfway oh yeah we're
going with them okay yeah
okay so i teach all online so i have my
own business teaching homeschool
students
so i can take it anywhere wow
well then this is just a great adventure
yeah yeah pretty good that's fun
that now we can take freely without debt
you know
yeah i absolutely gives us a little more
options and you now that you're making
some money instead of spending it all
yeah
all that stuff yeah that's good that's
good well good for you guys
good for you where'd you play your high
school um i moved away at
16 to play juniors in minnesota the
manitoba
virginia um and we both played college
hockey in upstate new york and then
transferred together to play in
pennsylvania so we've kind of been all
over yeah okay
cool cool well very cool good for you
guys
so how's it feel to be debt free after
all this gyration you've been through
such a relief yeah uplifting for sure so
amy where did you get this idea that
this is just unacceptable and we're
gonna crush it
i found the podcast the youtube channel
in college
just kind of trying to figure out what
the heck like how do you handle money
when you have bills and like real things
and what can we afford and
my dad's an accountant so money was
talked about in my house but
like the logistics as far as how are we
gonna handle that
so google couple google searches later
and your name pops up pretty
quick so then i got him to listen
it became mandatory lessons yeah and
trap him in the car
and you know yeah but it was kind of
like that mandatory job it didn't turn
out so bad
exactly exactly yeah pretty equivalent
yeah all right
very cool well i'm proud of you guys
very well done who are your biggest
cheerleaders outside the two of you
looking at you going you got this you
can do it and it's important
we had a lot of support i think my
parents let us live in their house for
rent free you know which helped us a lot
make progress and we're super supportive
my parents were supportive as well and
then also have to
throw out the name of my former teammate
in college brett johnson who
is a big ramsey uh supporter and is
currently debt-free himself using
the same plan wow yeah very cool so in
college we both got at t.j a little bit
you got to get honest
i was in the middle and finally cave in
and i'm happy
i'm happy i did yeah oh that's great
that's great we could use some hockey
analogies about you getting checked in
the corner but we won't
all right guys well done very well done
well we've got a copy of the legacy
journey for you
because that's what's happening you've
changed your entire legacy
by learning to work together and you've
had such a good sense of humor about it
and uh
you poked fun at each other but also got
serious and crushed it yeah
and uh very very well done that's good
communication style everything's awesome
you guys are rock stars
very very sharp young couple also got a
copy of the total money makeover for you
to give to somebody pay it forward maybe
you get someone else's journey started
with that
and that's the idea so what do you tell
people the secret to getting out of debt
is now that you've done it
i think for me you have to have a really
clear vision of what you want like some
of our best dates i think we're
just sitting down and talking about what
we want our future to look like and feel
like
and things we want to be able to do and
having that really clear vision then you
can kind of work backwards and
and work your plan as a clear like steps
to get there you know
but you have to have that clear vision
and not just kind of wander through it
and i i found a lot of similarities like
through hockey my whole life
my whole thing has been to learn to
enjoy the sacrifice
because you know that the payoff is
going to be fantastic and in hockey for
me everything was worth it so
i knew that it was going to be the same
way getting out of debt um so
just to learn to enjoy the pain and and
the suffering because you know
what comes at the end is is really worth
it yeah no discipline seems pleasant at
the time but it yields a harvest of
righteousness
well done you two very very well done
all right it's tj
and amy from california sweden 39
000 paid off in 10 months making 13 to
160. what a great story
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three
two one we're debt-free
this is how it's man
oh man oh man everybody here in the
audience is looking at them going
their future is bright everybody
watching on youtube is going their
future is bright
and if you look deeply into your radio
or your podcast you can look at them you
can see them right now and say their
future's bright
their future is amazing absolutely
incredible what a
cool couple power couple for sure very
fun stuff
very fun stuff this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today second corinthians 4
7 but we have this treasure
in jars of clay to show that this is all
surpassing
powers from god and not from us
john quincy adams says judy is ours
results
are god's it's our duty to plant the
corn then god sends the rain
and the sun we don't get to cause those
two things but guess what if you don't
plant the corn there won't
be any duty is ours results
are gods linda is with us in gilbert
arizona hi linda welcome to the ramsay
show
hi hi what's up hello
what i was calling because i have a
little boy well he's not that little
he's 15 years old
uh he's gonna be going to 10th grade um
he got his permit today uh so basically
in six months
he's gonna be able to drive by himself
um i
i drive a bmw and i'm gonna
pay it off by next month july it
shouldn't be paid off
um so i was i would you should give it
to him
uh or or not his dad passed away
when he like five years ago and i get um
social security for him i get like 13
like 13 40 a a month
and i don't know if you guys should like
uh
like what should i do with that money
should i put it in
in fidelity like that money should be
part of your budget
you spend more than 1300 a month to
raise a child
okay that's part of your budget and then
part of your budget is to raise the
child and part of your budget is to take
care of the child
and think about college and think about
cars and think about those kinds of
things
that money is not separate it's part of
your life
so because that's what i i i'm
planning to do just keep saving saving
the money like
like once i paint his car which is next
month uh
you know first god if he you feel my
life
um are you doing a monthly budget now
uh i'm in a start like yeah it's what if
i pay
this car you can start tonight you start
tonight when you get home
go to every dollar and download the
every dollar budget
app it's free to start using or go to
or go do a ramsey plus trial for free
which is even better
you can get the every dollar premium
version to start your budget
all of that and um
you know that'll make all the difference
in the world so you get that going and
then as a part of that you put this 1300
in there as a part of your income you
get take your income in the 1300
and that's what you have to operate your
household with and you pay off the car
as fast as you can possibly pay it off
and then as soon as it's paid off you
pay save up and pay cash
for of uh something for the 16 year old
to drive what year is this beamer
it's uh 2016. and what do you make a
year
i made like around 51 a year yeah and so
this beamer's worth
what i think it's worth 20 grand this
one was like 41.41 something like
that you don't give a 16 year old a 41
thousand dollar car
they'll tear it up like that because i
was feeling like basically houston
okay he needs has he has he has he
worked at all and saved any money
he wants to work but he's only 15 so he
cannot get a job
he can cut grass
they'll pay you for doing all that he
needs to make some money and you can put
some money with it and let's get him a
little five thousand dollar car
and you pay and you pay cash for it
okay okay you drive the beamer
so you don't think that i should like as
soon as i hit this car like just
sell sell it and then buy another one
that is affordable like with that cash
you could if you want to if you want to
sell it but don't put a 16 year old in a
20 000 car
[Music]
okay i've had 16 year olds i've raised
several of them
they don't drive well they bump into
stuff
and tear it up and you know your first
car
you know just get something to get them
around you know they'll be proud of it
it'll be fine
and and don't talk to me about it's not
safe it's safe
you're talking to a guy who used to
sleep in the back window of the car and
they slam on the brake and we'd roll
down into the floor
so you know and i survived it at least
some people think i did
um we're not sure about the brain damage
part but
but anyway yeah no hon just get him a
little car and if you want to move down
in car in your situation you're welcome
to i don't care
but don't hand a 16 year old
a 15 year old keys to a 40 000 beamer
no bad plan chrissy is with us in
vegas hi chrissy welcome to the ramsay
show
hi dave hey what's up how are you good
how can i help
um okay so i'm on the collection portion
of my dead snowball
um and um i just wanted to
know how i'm supposed to tackle it
because none of these um
places are actually like contacting me
or anything it's
most of them are like two years or more
so i only have their address
and then one of them is also an amex
that's not on my credit report anymore
so i just want to know how to tackle
them because i have all the money
already to pay them
okay good and you don't have any debts
that are active only old
debts that are in collection that's
correct okay
list them as best you understand the
balances
smallest to largest contact the smallest
one
and find out what you can settle that
for
because you may think it's a thousand
dollars and they may have run it up to
three thousand and you'll have to
negotiate and get it back down to a
thousand
uh what if they don't have a number it's
only an address
on the credit report you got to find
them
gotcha just jump online and start
looking for a number they're out there
they got a phone number
gotcha again for the next that's not on
my credit report anymore
same thing it doesn't matter if it's on
your credit bureau report or not you
still owe it
got it and they can still come sue you
got it so here's the rule okay
call them and they're going to act like
that all of a sudden they're
they're uh going to get aggressive which
is
humorous considering they haven't even
contacted you in years right
but they're all sudden going to go and
you're gonna go no no
no no no no so it's not a thousand it's
three thousand now well i'm not paying
three thousand
i i have a thousand dollars that says
you'll take it
and you negotiate with them and they say
okay we'll take a thousand dollars then
you have to get that in writing
say in writing chrissy
christie in writing if it's not in
writing it didn't happen when you're
dealing with collectors you can tell
they're
lying if their mouth is moving it's a
scummy business
okay in writing and then do not
give them electronic access to your
regular checking account
because they'll step in there and clean
your butt out okay
okay so you in writing and you can do a
wire transfer or prepaid debit card or
something else
but no electronic access to your
checking account do not let them have
get into your account because they'll
pull three thousand out after you agree
to a thousand and you're gonna have
trouble getting it back
right so in writing no electronic access
to checking account how many of these
debts are there
um just three and oh it's actually four
including the
next okay good whole lot because it's
gonna be a hassle
it's not going to be any it's not going
to be like one phone call and it's done
you're going to argue with them and call
them back and hang up on them and
they're going to call you
and it's just going to be a mess do not
give them a bunch of information on you
where do you work none of your business
i'm here on the phone trying to give you
money that's all you need to know
you got it and you listen i i know
you're you're a sweet person i can tell
by talking to you
i need the not sweet version of you on
the phone with them okay
okay because they're gonna be nasty now
you don't have to be nasty but i mean
you gotta be tough you with me
yes okay in writing no electronic access
to your checking account
that's how you do this stuff and you
settle this
and you work it through so good good
stuff
well that puts this particular hour of
the ramsey show in the books
our thanks to james childs our producer
kelly daniel our associate producer and
phone screener i
am dave ramsey your host we'll be back
with you before you know it
in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you